official delay of three hours
and ten minutes and eli morgan will be
our northeast ohio ford dealers indian
starting pitcher this afternoon
up the ladder he goes same pitch
fastball blew it by him one down craft
field everest 276 30 home runs 94 runs
batted in he's one of the scariest
hitters in the league for an opponent i
really do and there's a shot driven down
the line and it is out of here
scary scary scary indeed
number 31 and the red sox take the lead
as he drives in his 95th run
he's not out of august yet
yes he can be frightening
tanner howe going three 343 era tough
order for him today
the 3-2 is inside ball four
so he walks the lead off man
runner goes it's inside throw is not in
time
stolen base number 22 for miles strong
oh man did he help him out there a lot
of movement on that one and down he goes
that's that sweeping slider i was
talking about before
it's gonna be low for ball four well he
certainly has a style
there's a double play ball
beautiful
two down
bobby doll back up fiverr his last
eighties inning at 236. a little
three-game hitting streak for the first
baseman
swing and that one is hit high and deep
that one's sailing back kiss it goodbye
deep into the bleachers how about that
make that 25. a solo shot for his 17th
home run
418 feet
and the red sox lead it two to nothing
on a pair of solo home runs
swaying in a miss that was pretty
filthy right there to put him away that
was nasty
that disappeared man 86 miles an hour he
strikes out another one
second lead off walk by tanner howe
jimenez and almost hit him i think he
did
and the umpire says it did hit him and
he will take his base
a little ground ball here might be two
four to six
to three and they do turn the double
play
eli morgan lasted three innings
cleveland clinic hall of the bullpen has
been made for justin garza
on a full count sure did
strike three call martinez not happy
with home point umpire nick lentz that's
the fourth strikeout by a red sox hitter
today
a lion shot in a base hit xander going
the other way for a single with one down
sure he's talking about getting back
before the season's over
there's a base hit sharply into center
field
bogart's rounding he is off into third
base standing up and the red sox in
business first and third with one away
and the payoff pitch runner goes
swinging to miss and they don't throw
down and it's a stolen base for verdugo
his sixth
and a 3-2 to bobby dalbeck
and he held off it good take there for
ball four
i'd like to see jaren duran go with that
same approach that bogey went with and
verdugo taking the ball to the opposite
field
and walked him as he buried it that'll
bring in another run the red sox take a
three-nothing lead
xander bogart's trotting home
now the 3-0 delivery
outside ball four he walks ramirez on
four straight
brad mill looks it's low and how about
that back to back walks
after his team has just handed him a
three to nothing lead now that's four
already in the first
four innings
swinging a high fly ball that hangs up
duran underneath
got it
two men stranded still three nothing
socks
and he walked him so schwarber on as
he'll take the free pass here in the
fifth inning
smack the center mile straw got a great
jump on it and runs it down
jd martinez jd a couple of strikeouts
today struck out looking last inning
you know hitting and hitting the cage
he's gonna slug this one to center straw
is back turning that one catches the
wall
on his way to third here comes schwarber
he's gonna round
throw into third base nobody there
anyway another run in jd didn't miss one
by much there he's in the second base
with a run scoring double and it is now
four to nothing
jammed him big time soft roller bowl
guards quickly and gets him two down
he'll fly that one moving over verdugo
and makes the play
that's a one two three inning ball and
two strikes on plawecki
swung on and drill that one's deep
and that's off the wall played by
johnson plawecki digging and we'll get
there easily as the throw is just
slightly offline
oh two and there's a base hit to center
field
blowecky will trot into third stop there
2-2
nice
really nice job beautiful fastball by
stephanie it's a great tough part of the
order here getting him for the third
time
a high fly ball that's well struck
bardugo racing back to the track and he
makes the play
into the webbing
really nice play by verdugo and his
pitcher loves the effort ramirez has
walked and fouled out he'll swing it
left-handed
there's a drive to deep right field he
won't catch this one
long gone
ramirez with home run number 31. he
equals rafael nevers
for the most homers among third basemen
in baseball this year and gets the
indians on the board
and he hit him
second guy he's hitting the reyes will
take his base
hit him oh and flowecki immediately
complaining saying he
stuck his elbow out he didn't get out of
the way josh taylor on 1-0 343 era a
base hit here makes it a 4-3 ball game
the buffalo can
find some green grass out in the
outfield
and the o2
dragon base hit left center field
that'll score friend meal here comes
bradley zimmer
oh yes home on the range where zimmer
the deer and wilson the buffalo road
a two out two run single it's a one-run
game raphael since the home run has hit
a ball on the line to the center field
that was caught he's also popped up so
he's one for three
there's a high fly ball he leaned into
that one that's way back there watch
this one go he's got another one
rafael devers his second of the day he's
got you giggling this guy
he just he just gets a hold of this ball
and just launches it
and right okay
buffalo goes to second they get the lead
but no throw to first by
two
rosario
i don't know if his leg went out from
underneath him when he went to make that
throw to second ramos down in the heat
jeff desjardins quickly to talk to him
he's pointing at his knee
can he put any weight on it at all
it doesn't look like no it sure doesn't
that's that's a shame
does not look like
look oh my goodness a rifle shot into
center field by robles and by
the diving munoz that ball had to be 110
off the bat because he was lucky to get
out of the way
here's jose ramirez one swing of the bat
we've got a new game
jose high drive deep left center field
and it's off the wall
coming around and scoring is rosario
it's a one-run game we're in the eighth
inning two outs nobody on a 2-2 count on
the hedges
deep left field onto the porch it goes
he got him
a two out solo home run ties the game at
five
and the go-ahead run is aboard with two
down in the eighth inning and yu chang
coming to the plate
that's a fair ball down the left-field
line mccombatto can fly he's in the 30
ran into the shortstop
interference
but now let's see what the umpires
decide interference is called yeah they
give them the run the indians take the
lead that was smart base running they
kept waving them there was interference
he saw that and he's going to hit home
plate and they're going to give him home
play chang is now at third top of the
order miles straw
and there's a letter off the glove of
bogarts another run is in as chang comes
home and miles strong
with his first hit of the afternoon
for the 58th time this year a 146 era
[Music]
what a job by this ball club today
coming from behind
[Applause]
you